good evening and welcome to this
Northwest area planning meeting held
today 5th of October 2022. my name is
councilor Maddie Thompson and I'm
chairman of this committee before we
commence the business of the meeting
there are a few housekeeping issues to
run through
we're streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent to being recorded
when invited to speak members please use
the microphone speak clearly referencing
a page or paragraph number when
referring to the agenda papers please
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible and ensure your
microphones remain off when not speaking
as this is important for the live
streaming to be heard clearly
finally can I draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit is the
door behind the top table
right members may I draw your attention
to the members update with further
information on item five on the agenda
so item two is apologies for absence
Miss Casey
thank you chairman we received apologies
for absence from councilman civil thank
you thank you very much item three is
minutes um it's recommended that the
minutes of the meeting held on 9th of
September found on pages seven and eight
are approved as a true and accurate
record may I take them as red members
for Monday okay
um I so propose seconded anybody
oops
thank you I'll be back to you right that
was seconded by councilor Morgan thank
you and finally
um any matters of accuracy yes thank you
councilor Stevens I got the wrong date
they are correct on the agenda papers
yes
slip of the brain sorry
right so now I think four Declarations
of Interest
this is now different
um
no sorry this is left over from last
time we have now the correct wording in
in the published agenda but I'll read it
anyway to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests out that registerable interest
and non-registerable interests relating
to items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph 9 and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members and members are reminded they're
also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the need arise through the
meeting councilor Durham
thank you chairman chairman um although
I'm the councilors say it's not
necessary I will declare another
registerable interest of some member of
Essex County Council through a statutory
consultees and in the interest of
openness and transparency
um I was aware of the applicant when I
was in the Gulf business
um but that is not for the last 10 years
and it was a
business acquaintance no um nothing more
than that
um so yeah okay thank you very much
uh anyone else no okay so item five
which is our first and indeed only
planning application uh it's the golf
driving range Burnham Road or the
Mortimer there is the members update as
I said earlier on that lab we do have
the agent to speak after the
presentation so Mrs Turner please thank
you chairman this is an outline
application with all matters reserved
for up to 18 residential units The
Proposal would also involve the
demolition of the existing building on
the site and the removal of the driving
range and pitch and Putt use
so you have the location plan the site
outlined in red measuring um
approximately 3.4 hectares
the indicative layout plan because as
I've said it's all matters reserved and
there's an area of public open space
proposed within the site a mix of two
three and four but units are proposed
there's going to be eight affordable
housing units and which would be four
point it would be 4.4 over and above the
requirement and this basically takes the
the policy requirements 7.2 units and
eight would be delivered this is
considered to be a de minimis figure and
doesn't provide significantly above the
policy requirement
it's also worth noting this stage that
policy H5 has been referenced within the
submission that's the rural exception
scheme policy which the application
hasn't been put forward as and there's
been no evidence submitted with the
application in respect of local need to
meet those policy requirements there'll
be some additional tree planting across
the site
um and within the area the area of
public open space there's an existing
public footpath along the western
boundary of the site to conduit Lane
and and which could provide
access to the bus stops but it's
unlikely that these this footpath would
be used for this reason and due to it
being unlit and involving walking within
a road so it's considered that users
would probably be deterred from using it
in dark times or in periods of inclement
weather
oops
it's also worth noting although the
layout's indicative we don't consider
there to be much room for change due to
the number of units proposed the needs
for sud scheme and the public open space
and for it to be set back from Burnham
Road
so officers could have concerns over the
spread of development and the
encroachment of built form in the
countryside and the visibility from
public Vantage points particularly from
the footpath and Burnham Road
so here we have the tree constraints
plan so the majority of trees to be
removed and we're in the footprint of
where the
um houses are shown
so just um for it relevant to highlight
the site history to you there's been two
previous applications at the site for 25
units and they were refused due to
impacts on the character interference of
the area the accessibility and
sustainability credentials of this site
the unjustified loss of employment
tourist community and sports and Leisure
uses and the lack of a science section
106 agreement for the various different
contributions
one other application in 2017 was
dismissed on a pill which was for eight
dwellings
at the time of the 2021 application the
council couldn't demonstrate a five-year
housing land supplier and so the
considerations in that respect are
um the same for this application
it was previously considered that 25
units would not offset the harm as a
result of the inappropriate and
unsustainable location the loss of the
employment and generating
the loss of the employment use the
community tourism and Sport facility
this scheme proposes lesser units and
therefore is considered that the
existing new lawful use still has a
greater community community benefit than
the proposed
so just for your reference this is the
2017 application layout for the eight
units
the 2020 for the 25 and the 2021 for the
25
. so here I have some photos of the site
access sort of within the access and
around it
photos looking out um from the access
onto Burnham Road
within the driving range and then you
have the building for that purpose here
and the pitch and part section of the
site
so the location is considered to be
unsustainable and inaccessible so be a
Reliance on the use of the private motor
car
it would fundamentally appraisal
fundamentally alter the open character
of the southwestern edge of the village
failing to provide a visual enhancement
to The Wider rural locality it would
represent the encroachment of built form
into the rural site and the sprawl of
development into the open Countryside
it's not considered that the loss of the
employment news Community facility
tourism facility and sports and Leisure
facility has been Justified
you're also aware of the members update
that as an additional reason for refusal
in relation to ecology and because the
information is outdated so we can't be
sure that there won't be detrimental
impacts on protective species
and so in consideration of the bug it's
not considered that there are material
new material considerations in respect
of the previous application that would
alter the council starts on this
application or overcome those concerns
and so it's recommended for refusal
thank you chairman
thank you so Mr O'Toole
if you'd like to come forward please
pick any chair you like
um please use the microphone someone
will help you with that if you like you
have two minutes precisely and I'm
afraid I am very precise but it starts
when you begin to speak okay good
evening the council has significantly
failing to provide a five-year housing
land supplier and themselves deferment
the site was sustainable and should be
developed back in 2015 the scheme has
received overwhelming support from the
council's own consultees who have
explicitly welcomed the provision of
much needed affordable housing
additionally there's been overwhelming
support from the parish council and the
surrounding neighborhood the officers
report significantly downplays the
sustainability of the site walking
cycling public transport and private
vehicle are all viable routes of travel
to and from this site
as a local network or public footpaths
connecting the site to bus stops that
are serviced by frequent bus routes not
just the one outlined in the officers
report as stated in the offices report a
council appraisal in 2021 determined
that the development would have a
minimal impact on the wider landscape
significant additional soft landscaping
and tree planting is proposed which will
have huge environmental and ecological
benefits
open green space Also forms part of The
Proposal facilities which will benefit
The Wider community
the viability of the business is
dwindling and costs of maintaining the
site are skyrocketing evidence has been
provided that there is a wealth of other
golf facilities within the borough the
existing use is detrimental to
neighboring properties the site is no
longer fit for use in fact a golf ball
went through a neighbor's window this
weekend
the application explicitly states that
affordable housing will be provided and
a draft section 106 agreement was
included within the design access
statement the client cannot progress
with legal agreements until the number
of units and the housing mixes agreed
this is the council's policy and is to
be resolved as part of a reserve matters
application
as well as providing much needed housing
for the borough the proposed development
would bring significant improvements to
the surrounding neighbors and wider
village community the benefits far
outweigh the perceived concerns and this
application should be granted permission
thank you perfect timing too
thank you
all right um
members I've got you first Council of
Durham
oh thank you chairman
um and members I apologize for bringing
you out on the Thursday night just for
this one item which I I went to the
United okay sorry it does seem like
Thursday no idea
um
but I did feel that there were adequate
reasons why this should be brought to
committee can we bring up the site plan
please with the
no yeah the one no the next one up yeah
that one that one yeah
okay so the the first point I will make
is that it's actually quite a natural
infill
um with the rest of the village and in
terms of the settlement boundary
it actually does run along one side of
this if not two sides of this and
particular
um proposed development I just want to
address one or two of the things in in
the officer's report and and I'm very
sorry to
um pick holes in in the report
um but uh
firstly I I contest that actually this
is a sustainable location I mean I know
there are no shops there are no
facilities in wood and Mortimer
but uh it's exactly 475 meters from the
nearest bus stop which is not I wouldn't
have said terribly far
um which is on on the a414 which is the
main route between Chelmsford and Malden
um the agent has mentioned damage to
local properties and when I was in the
same business I had exactly the same
issue the problem the fundamental
problem with the current
driving range as such
uh and I'd you know I I
I'm not sorry to say that I'm an expert
in this but the golf
looks uh golf has changed significantly
golf equipment has changed significantly
in the last 20 years
and anybody watching it on television
will see in that the Improvement in
equipment means that people hit the ball
much much further
and this is a very old driving range and
it fundamentally is just too short
so that is why Bulls are going over the
existing fence
the in the officers report it did
mention doubling the height of the fence
and I accept the fact that that would
stop Bulls from going over the fence to
a certain extent but people aren't going
to pay to hit balls into a fence it's
completely pointless
so I'm afraid that the times has caught
up with this as a viable driving range
in terms of it being a tourist
attraction
come on I really don't think that it is
a valid tourism
um operation and I speak as the chairman
of visit Essex and it's not something
that features terribly in uh in in the
tourism Spectrum
also uh by uh by all accounts
um
and and actually Gemini should declare
an interest in that I have bought a gas
cylinder there this winter so one gas
cylinder so apologies for that because
it does Supply probably not at a
discounted rate because of your position
I wish it was have you seen the price of
Calor Gas thank you very much indeed
it's just another customer I just said
just another customer because
um uh it was too it's too expensive it
does it's too expensive everywhere now
but anyway that's a and there's just
there's just appears to be one lad
working there who runs around doing all
sorts of everything so I don't actually
think it's a very significant um
employment opportunity
um and and I wouldn't say that the
business would support more than more
than a couple of Staff anyway
then we come to
the ecology
now this is an area of closely known
grass that not only has a mower across
it probably in the summer
in the growing season twice a week
but in order to pick the balls up you
either have a tractor or a similar
device and the ball collecting machine
has large plastic discs
so the chance of anything surviving more
than about
two minutes on there is slightly
well it would be very unlikely they'd be
very unlikely anything
um bigger than a golf ball would be very
unlikely to survive in fact even then
smaller so I you know I don't really
accept that there's a terribly
valid ecological
um
ecological uh objection to this
fundamentally the parish council and the
main reason I called it in the parish
councilor completely in support of it
Asar pretty much all of the the
surrounding
neighbors and in terms of visual impact
actually from the Burnham Road the
existing building is not the most
not the most uh desirable and I think it
would actually
be an improvement so
um chairman and going back over the
planning history are somewhere in the
depths of my mind
and the agent did
hint to it was the fact that I think
there was was it assessed for with about
70 houses potential initially whether
that was a pre-app or whether that was
in the
in the original Shema
sorry
um that sticks in my mind I mean this is
a big sight
um the difference between this one and
the previous application that was turned
down for Eight houses and you might say
eight would be better than 25 but when
you look at it they were eight humongous
great houses
which quite honestly is not what the the
people in the village wanted so the mix
of these is actually uh fits in with
with what is required in the village and
I think if you go on to right move
you would find it impossible to find a
house for sale in wooden Mortimer less
than a million pounds
um in fact I know you wouldn't so you
know the these are there is local need
for these and um
so
chairman that that is the reason why I
think that we should make an exception I
would like to hear from Mr Lee
um or the officer
um whether this will make us I'm not
going to use the word significant an
impact to a five-year land Supply issue
I would have said it must do I mean it's
not hundreds of houses but it probably
would would help I I would guess
so um Mr Lee is looking at got his his
uh
he he's he's got his uh the look on his
face and and I would actually like to
take this opportunity to say we're
really sorry that you're going to be
leaving us Mr Lee because
okay
um no I must say over over the eight
years you you have you've been an
absolutely excellent officer and you
know we've had many a conversation and
we haven't always agreed but you will be
a great loss to the authority and but um
anyway that's enough
um schmoozing to Mr Lee but uh I don't
think it's going to work no I don't
think
chairman I I had absolutely no
expectation that it would and I know
exactly where Mr Lee is going to come
from but I do think that there are
significant factors in this that means
it should be supported thank you
thank you um sorry I've got a whole rug
people to speak do you want to come yeah
thank you chairman
um so in terms of the bus service and
sustainability it's probably best to
um deal with those together so the bus
service is understanding an hourly
service to Malden and runs only from 8am
till 5 30. so I would give Limited
options for those trying to get to and
from work
um part of the main concern is that you
would need to access the the bus stop on
conduit Lane
um is the most limited service for both
that bus stop and the one on Bryant's
Lane would need to be accessed through
the public footpath through the site
which was the concerns in relation to
being unlit and not a sort of a
desirable option for those looking to
travel on foot and in terms of
sustainability The Village itself is one
of the smaller villages with limited
services and Facilities so I wouldn't
provide everything that people need for
day-to-day living so although the site
is adjacent to the settlement boundary
as you said
um
there's quite a lot of housing to be
put onto that Village in itself and in
terms of the Gulf
need
[Music]
um
it's not been demonstrated that
you know the level that that is being
used to us
a sufficient amount for us to be able to
determine that you know it's not a
worthwhile and well used
um
surprisingly for a commodity to the
district and but also in terms of it
being a tourist
facility or Community facility
we potentially I'm not saying we
definitely could but would look to
support something else on that site
within those uses and that hasn't been
explored so the policy looks for it for
those for it to be marketed for other
options falling within those uses before
we allocate it for housing and we
haven't had any evidence as part of that
in terms of ecology there are trees
within the site and
um Hedges surrounding the site so the
the point of ecology is just that the
survey is outdated and we just can't be
sure at the moment that there isn't any
protective species on the site that
could be affected they could come out at
night
uh just for clarity the employee numbers
in the application form were one full
time and three part-time staff
um and
respect of the schla and the because I
was put forward in the recent call for
Science and was deemed to be unsuitable
for development and it was never
allocated through the
um last local plan period either for
housing so anything the previous slide
would carry no weight at this point
and the last point I think was in
relation to the impact on the five-year
housing land supplier the number of
units would be considered fairly Limited
in terms of its benefits for the
five-year Supply
there is that very slight over provision
of affordable housing but other than
that there isn't any benefits that would
be over and above what we would normally
expect to see if a planning application
and planning applications of this size
unfortunately don't bring forward more
substantial benefits in terms of
Education contributions transport
contributions things like that so it is
a limited number that wouldn't
substantially alter that thank you
can I just come back on one point I'm
chairman if that's okay
um just in relation to the bus services
as members will know tomorrow there's a
Malden District future transport
strategy members Workshop which is part
of the Essex County Council sustainable
transport strategy which is all about
getting people out of their cars onto
buses so what the bus service we have
now
is unlikely to be the same bus service
as we have when this strategy is
published so that is a that is a moving
Feast if you like
um so yeah and
yeah I I hear what the the officer says
and I now wait with baited breath to
hear what Mr Lee says yes
thank you chairman um just want to make
a couple of points a bit more strategic
than specifically on the points that the
Miss herna raised um well I always say
as always is we're here to make
decisions on evidence as planning
officers we're not hitting decision
makers that's whether it's the committee
delegated the inspector
um a lot as Ms herner said in the office
report explains there's a lot of
submission but not knitting a lot of
evidence as part of the application and
with all due respect to council Diamond
a lot of what he said is opinion based
rather than factual evidence-based um
because what the point is we do not have
the evidence in front of his decision
makers to make those informed definitive
conclusions it may well be we all think
this is likely to be the answer but
without that evidence we cannot make
that decision categorically
um and for example would point about the
employment and the golf course Etc the
policy doesn't require it that it has to
be a golf course there are lots of other
opportunities it could be but they
haven't marked it to even see if anyone
is interested in providing any of those
uh facilities or Community uses or
employment opportunities would actually
be where the policy directs development
to before moving it to housing housing
was basically the last
option in our policy and none of the
other considerations have been a
brought forward I'll jump to councilor
Down's last point because of Miss
herness I had a chance to respond to
that and in relation to uh what may be
in the future and policies in the future
and it's a moving face unfortunately
we're eating to unfortunately we're
eating today though we need to eat what
is in front of us and the evidence is
what in front of us and what we are
where we are now what may happen in the
future is not because situation for us
today in this decision
um down to the point just to add a
couple of points onto what Miss herner
did say it will highlighters you know
sort of said that the site is a smaller
Village
there's a large selection of smaller
Villages within our policy sa including
uh Towson Darcy Thompson major
tillingham
um you know Stone Mary's little totem
Etc there's a lot of these Villages and
if we are to accept that we are going to
build houses in these sites and consider
them sustainable when they have no
facilities and a very limited bus
service that is the same for every
single Village it's not just for this
application it's for every application
and remember that is not one house or
two houses that is whether it's one or
four hundred houses if we consider these
spillages sustainable as decision makers
they are sustainable for the council and
every application we have that comes
before us will have to have the right
respect to have the same considerations
applied that application and this is why
I always raise concerns with throwing
the bath the baby out with the bath
water in our policies because they do
reflect an impact on every single
application we have and also in relation
to council Diamond's point about the
schla it's seven years old now
um we didn't give it weight then we won
appeals when we didn't give it away when
inspect when the applicants tried to and
what I'd also say is the Comfort sites
is much more recent and if we're going
to give the slide at seven years old
wait we'll have to start giving the uh
all the sites that have been positively
allocated within the call for sites a
lot of weight and I would say that is a
very dangerous consideration for members
to start doing because there's a lot of
sites have been greenlighted through
that process and if we start giving away
for the schlot from all that time ago
we're going to have to start doing that
now thank you chairman thank you very
much
I'm addressing um comments that Mr Lee
said um I would probably count myself as
an expert witness in respect of the golf
industry at the time this was more than
10 years ago we had a driving range
facility that was of a similar length
and it was just too short and it costs
you actually have to buy short-range
golf balls that don't fly as far and
nobody wants to nobody wants to do it
because it's not the real game so you
know that that side of things you know
yes it isn't it is not suitable bearing
in mind that just down the road at Three
Rivers at Cold Norton she's just down
the other end of the road is a big
driving range with flood lights and
unfortunately for these facilities
you have to have floodlights so you
don't so that you are viable in the
evening so you have this you have three
rivers you have condom Park which you
can see from the other side of the a12
the time has moved on the business has
moved on and as another example of the
fact that the golf industry is in
Decline and there as you might remember
chairman the Warren put in an
application to remove some of their golf
holes because simply that part wasn't
viable although we are appealing
appealing that decision quite rightly
but on different uh different matters
but thank you oh shut up now
response obviously I apologize I wasn't
clear in my thing but the policy doesn't
say it has to attack the obtain as a
golf course it just says there are other
things that could be done before it goes
to housing no comment I may relate to it
being retained to golf course so if that
wasn't clear I apologize I apologies
just say that there should be employment
tourism Community facilities Etc across
the board and the breadth of what they
could be rather than going to housing
first so if I wasn't clear I do
apologize thank you chairman
Morgan councilor right and then
councilor Morley so Council
thank you madam chairman yes um firstly
can I also say how sorry I am to hear Mr
Lee leaving us going into a short short
period being here
um
for what he's been able to do
um but I have to say and endorse uh well
fellow councilors Durham's
um sort of
uh remarks here and I I really am
particularly persuaded by the fact that
the parish council is supporting this
um and indeed a number of other local
residents so I mean we don't have nimb
these here we've got yimbees yes in my
backyard and I think that in in terms of
the sustainability and I take the point
to Mr Lee has said in regards to uh
evidence but I don't actually seem to be
to be perfectly honest for my reading of
it that the evidence of unsafe
sustainability is actually made made
here there are for so she said they said
there's a pub in the village there's any
there's a a
um coffee shop indeed there's the um
garden center it's very close to Danbury
I don't see that that's sustainable is
is it is unsustainable at all
um and so also you say that
um it should be if there's going to be
anything put on here instead of a golf
driving rate should be some other sports
facility but or some other what I've had
on a loss to think what you could put on
there to be honest unless you sort of
build a huge gymnasium or something and
so I have to say that I I think that I
mean in fact I'm sort of at the loss of
the time when um you know we we have no
five-year land Supply there is a call
for sites Etc somebody's come forward
and a village has been prepared to put
18 houses with it why are we out biting
their arm off at the shoulder think
about it
um I've got quite a few things I could
say to that but Mr Mrs
yeah thank you Jimmy I just wanted to
clarify
um the parish council's comment so they
have tipped the we raise no objection
but wish to make the following comment
box in the response form and which isn't
listed as being in support of the
application
um they know that the previous
applications were generally supported by
themselves with concerns and
recommendations they've resolved again
to support the application but as it's
understood that many nearby residents
are welcome in the cessation of the
current activities currently causing
nuisance away with golf balls and light
pollution and then there's some concerns
about surface water I think that just
highlights what myself and Mr Lee have
said about
the parish concerns appear to me to be
without speaking on their behalf but
from reading this is that at least the
activities that they want to see to the
site and that that doesn't mean for me
that we need to put housing on the site
there are many options that we could
explore and with regards to what you
were saying about what could go on there
there's under the Community facility
policy there is a number of things
listed in there
um of course it is seen as a sport
facility as well so if we can retain
that then great but there are quite a
few different Community facilities that
fall under that definition that won't
need to be in the same sort of vein as
what's there at the moment
thank you chairman
thank you chairman just on that point
I'd say it's not before us as a
committee so we can't give that anyway
as always secondly what I would like to
say and I would very much like to
highlight as I have said a million times
in committees and hopefully not many
more times
um
planning is not the X Factor we're not
here to term in applications on
popularity case law is clear that we are
here to make applications based on
policies and there's material situations
indicate otherwise and popularity both
for and against an application is not a
material consideration of any way so
whether or not the principal of the
public Parish anybody else is either for
or against an application is not a
material consideration it's the quality
of the comments that are raised not the
volume that is the important fact so I
know what councilman said but please do
not take that Council Morgan into
thought when you come to vote on this
application because that is something
that case law has said is not a material
consideration determinational
application thank you chairman
thank you I mean I I have a concern
myself but if we're saying it's
sustainable as Mr Lee's just said that
applies to 400 the same as 18. it just
does and in fact we've got an appeal
upcoming in our village councilman all
he told us at nights for 97 houses and
um so if we're saying that what a
Mortimer is sustainable
why won't the inspector find that tons
of nice is sustainable
what it's possible no Maiden
it's possible they may do but you know
welcome to your chairman full point
um every decision this committee makes
or the council makes is a material
consideration if we start making
decisions that say that the threshold
for sustainability is much louder than
we historically have taken that will
become the position as members that were
here at the time the last five year land
supplies said we lost a lot of appeals
towards the end because inspectors were
being convinced that the council has
been inconsistent on its determination
of sustainability and we lost a lot of
appeals on the fact that inspect agents
were able to evidence that and what I
would say is as we know now they're all
online agents are watching a lot more
committees are able to see much more of
our decisions and we are seeing them
Turner can agree
regularly
uh where there's an inconsistency
particularly through committees than
being referenced in appeals because
people are able to review them much
quicker and easier than historically
they could do due to the fact they had
to be in the Champions directly thank
you thank you right I've got Miss White
next Council White
uh thank you madam chairman um well my
comments really I've been going through
the um policy map
and um for me uh under S1
a lot of it is previously developed land
um which is where we should be basing
any building decisions and I will say
that every planning application should
be based but decided determined on its
own merits so you know what else comes
before us I can't talk about I only talk
about what's here tonight
um I believe it is sustainable because
there is bus stops there are local
businesses
um and we have allowed
um a local development lately that was a
business which is just over the road
um under part nine of this one it says
that will conservatively enhance the
natural environment um with to get a net
increase in biodiversity now I know that
regardless of the um report mode grass
has very little nature or biodiversity
gains or benefit because it is mode so
it's not conducive to Nature
um and the agreement is down to the
authority to do a careful agreement of a
new biodiversity measure will add a
benefit to what is already there so
therefore it's a net gain this is also
applicable to policy N1 and N2 which is
green infrastructure gains maximizing
opportunities for on-site and The Wider
community and policy in two which is
biodiversity gains no net loss and gains
on site well this if if we manage the
um biodiversity carefully this will be a
huge gain because it needs to be mixed
um increases so that's something that I
think we can do and I think depending on
what decision is that's something that
would need to be decided by officers or
members or probably officers to get the
gain that we need
um
part five bus stops and local businesses
I mean let's face it Danbury is pretty
easy to get the bus stop from and again
it is only just across the road
um we've also had various appeals that
stated that it was reasonable for rural
areas to use a car
and we've lost on Appeal on that point I
can't remember which application it was
um then we go on to policy S3 which is
Place shaping
um you know the neighbors are Keen to
gain public access to land which is not
currently available to the public so for
me that's
um again on S3 part two
um where places where people want to
live and interact through active
citizenship um so because we we're
actually creating additional Green Space
so for me that's a positive rather than
a negative
um policy H2
um it is if I'm correct increasing
affordable housing which is so that for
me complies with that policy because we
keep being told we've got to do it
um policy on policies that I've been
going through the policies while I've
been sitting here this evening jet
lagged I'm still going through policies
um and policy H4 interestingly 5.26
um it says it's happy to build on
smaller scale housing developments if
they will develop affordable housing um
so that's something that I think would
be interesting to look into
um they don't be told why that's not
applicable and then again policy N1
green infrastructure gains yeah that for
me that box is ticked it's maximized
opportunities for on-site and The Wider
Community because currently excluding
the footpath the public can't access it
so that's another one
um and part two uh policy N2 the
biodiversity gains no net loss and and
gains on site I mean if we're careful we
could get a massive biodiversity
increase on here and and I think
depending on what decision is we should
put this for future discussion because
we could make this a really really big
gain so for me personally depending on
what comes up from the offices the um
harm outweighs oh sorry the benefit
outweighs any perceived harm and every
application is on its Merit so for me
that's that's where I am yeah yes thank
you chairman um I'll just say it
personally I think most of the points
councilor lights highlighted
in compliance with policy on neutral
such as affordable housing that's
required to be there it's not actually a
benefit their requirements but what I
would highlight is that particularly
reasons refusal where it talks about
Ewan E3 5 and N3 there's been no
discussion about the conflict with those
and to give a scheme basically saying
it's got a house and it's got affordable
there should be net gain Etc let's not
worry about employment let's not worry
about the rules of the employment land
our community facility Etc is a very
dangerous decision because while each
application on his own Merit you still
need to talk about this application and
I think the actual harm that is
highlighted in the office of Paul has
been discussed by Ms herner by himself
is even if you just look at Reason fusel
3 is there and
taking such a broad brush approach to
say that there are net gain affordable
housing Etc is a reason to go against
those four policies would be very
dangerous for every other application
that is unemployment land or is on
Community Land and secondly as miss
herner explained previously H5 relates
to all exception site and this isn't a
real exception site they haven't done
the evidence to it the specific need for
the board Etc so that is a moot point
Thank You chairman thank you thank you
and I do still have a problem with it
there's no advertising that's part of
the policy and that's
that's a requirement it's not happened
and you know a couple of months ago we
committed as a whole made a decision to
support a business in the country so I
don't know we're making sure the land is
lost to a business
um right I have got Council oh sorry
yeah so just in respect to the point of
net biodiversity gain and I think it's
important to consider the ecology our
ecology consultant has said that this
site has the potential to impact on
priority species and they've said that
under our statutory Duty that we need to
be considering this prior to the
determination of the application so a
letter might be a net buy the rest of
Getting By proving this they could be
detrimental impacts on ecology that
can't be reversed and we don't have any
mitigation
um
ecological appraisal to condition you
know there could be bats in the trees
and things like that that we could be
impacting on
I will come back to councilor Durham but
not yet because it's uh councilor Morley
followed by Council Stevens yeah thank
you chairman um yeah just to Mr Lee as a
general rule of thumb I
if you have a business like that are you
really meant to offer it
to other businesses first before you go
for planning and and also
because it's not Farmland does that give
it weight
to uh thank you for you chairman um I'll
answer those questions backwards if
that's okay
um yeah the site is previously developed
language obviously is where we would
encourage development that isn't just
housing that is any form of development
you then move on to our policies which
looks to protect various uses we have
with its employment communities
Etc because there's a need for them if
there is an Evidence lack of a need so
you would do marketing Etc then
there is an acceptance that they will be
lost but it's a point of going through
that getting over those hurdles and this
applicant hasn't submitted that what I'd
use as an example is the Malden Police
Station where application came in to use
it for uh residential development we
refused on lack of evidence and that
they'd actually tried to Market it to
higher value actually
um and we won that appeal and
subsequently we've now had an
application but to be converted into
employment land so we shouldn't assume
because part of their submission was no
we want this for employment land we
aren't here to make assumptions we're
here to make decisions based on evidence
and there is a silence on these facts
and it's very dangerous I would say for
members to make decisions to go against
our employment policies out and all
these other policies based on
assumptions and how you feel it may be
in six months time 12 months time we're
back here with a different
recommendation on those points but until
they've done that evidence we should not
as decision makers be ignoring that
requirement because it will undermine
every single application we have on
employment land Etc and as I said this
will become the council standard we will
just be ignoring parts of the policy and
that is you know I know we're doing
local plan view but in reality the local
plan is still quite young it's only five
years old and we shouldn't be taking
that approaches my advice members
thanks actually a couple of questions
it's been refused before on various
um numbers of houses has anything
changed that has made it sustainable
when it was there was a reason for
refusal before
no there's no new material
considerations change our stance thank
you right I've got councilor Stevens
followed by councilor keys
and if we haven't set up our sleeping
bags I'll come back to you Council again
Council Stevens thank you chair
I feel a bit like if you were in a
courtroom and the judge was saying
you've got to ignore that just don't
hear that he said that you would have to
ignore it and every time I come to these
meetings we seem to just go well yeah I
know it says it's only a small
unsustainable Village in the ldp but
well actually I don't really believe in
that we can't do that if we've got
policies we have to stick by them if we
change our ldp well then that's the
moment we can say yeah let's put all the
development into this Village we'll make
it a sustainable Village and and let's
throw bricks at it we'll we can do that
we've got the power to do that but
that's not where we are at the moment
um
as as Mr Lee Amazon have said there
isn't the evidence and I think I would
look at this application again in time
to come if different evidence comes
forward with a different mindset but
right now I can't see any evidence
because there isn't any it's not com um
compliant with our policies that would
allow it we've heard all the reasons why
and I think we need to think really
really carefully before we just Chuck
those policies out of the window or they
they become worthless and next time
we'll just have to say yes to anything
else that comes and we'll keep saying
yes and we'll get built over thank you
thank you Council case
hey Madam chairman um sometimes I come
to these meetings I'll say quite a lot
of times when I come to these meetings
now last week I think all of us bought
councilor White
sat in looking at a garden suburb now
that is what I would class as a garden
suburb now the run down the road Malden
Council said we should approve
the recommendation for all these houses
and there was all complaints about you
couldn't get the dust car Emergency
Services down there all these houses
from what I can see in here have all got
garages and from what I can see out
there they've all got off-road parking
this is Brownfield site the one down the
road that we passed and you can argue
sustainability I might be in 50 in
November but I wouldn't want to walk
from Morrisons which our class is
sustainable to get me shopping back to
that development with three or four bags
of shopping
now this
Brownfield site Greenfield site down the
road
we've got to look at it like this that
is nice it's in a village it's on the
edge it's virtually surrounded by houses
as councilor Durham says it's in the
village envelope
borders the village envelope it's cut
grass
we've got a wildlife area there now
which will probably grow longer grass
and as my fellow members have said cut
grass has got no apart from the odd ant
hill
you are not going to have any sort of
animal
on there this is nice I like this
thanks
um firstly I'd be very
um reluctant to hear the phrase this is
nice I like this in committee again you
know
here is you're here to terminate
application and less material
considerations can whether I like this
and think this is nice or not is
irrelevant and it's irrelevant for every
decision maker you are here to turn an
application called to a development plan
and let's material considerations
indicate otherwise so as always I say
can you please be very conscious the
terminology and wording you use because
we aren't here to decide what's nice or
not nice we're here to look at policies
we're not here to go I think that's
pretty or that's but unless we'll see
coming down to design aspect in relation
to council Casey's point about uh the
garden suburbs first you'll see the gun
suburb is a lot bigger Quantum of
development so I don't think it's a
directly comparable
but also the reason is that the
government require us to live a certain
amount of Housing and it should be dealt
with through the plan-led system more
District Council when it submitted the
local planning uh 2014 a chosen the
approach of delivering Garden suburbs so
the Quantum of housing that we needed as
a district was decided to be delivered
through developments attached to
haybridge Malden and Burnham that was
the way we decided to do it and that is
why we have allocated sites that is why
we had the reserve matters outline
applications Etc and additional events
for those that was the way we have
chosen to uh deliver housing it's
accepted I think by anybody that if
you're going to build a house but it's
one or a hundred there's going to be
some level of harm and you have to make
the Judgment of how you cause that harm
or where there's the less harm and
longest it counts before I worked here
so you know I'll leave that's councilor
Thompson cats down and cancel well I
think only to comment on that but that
was the options that the council decided
whether or not you agree with it's
irrelevant that is the situation if we
have allocated sites and we are to live
in housing through that way this is not
an allocated site it's a completely
different situation and you should not
compare an allocated site to a whimful
site you can't compare a site for how
many thousand houses to a site for 18
houses and I just advise members uh not
to do that and there was a third Point
counselor case right and I can't pull it
was so ecology yeah and as I would say
is that okay as a glass may be cut but
remember that there are a number of
trees on this site that will be removed
secondly things such as bats Etc don't
live in the grass so they may well
interact with the site we just you know
Ecology of raised that this site could
have protect spaces and to say that we
there isn't because we don't think there
is sitting here is the issue there is
not evidence in before us to confirm
there isn't so irrespective what you
feel about any of the other reasons for
a few so I'd be very concerned with us
sitting around this table to decide we
have of experts on the issue of ecology
went out supposed experts that we pay
money to give us consultations and they
don't have enough evidence to make that
decision and that would just be my
comment thank you chairman thank you
I'm just going to take up that point
about a point about trees because the
the right hand side of that development
is currently a golf driving range and
we've seen the photographs of it so
those trees shown on the plan are new
trees
it's a completely flat grass area the
left hand side is the pitch and part and
those existing trees are there I I think
they're going to stay stay there so
um you're exchanging what you see in the
right hand side of the
site from a flat grass field I'm just
going to raise
the high court case of Dartford Borough
Council versus the Secretary of State in
2015.
which looks at the diversifying land in
the countryside and they held that
residential Gardens outside of built up
areas were Brownfield land and not
Greenfield land this is significant
because paragraph one one of the mppf
provides that Brownfield land
ought to be prioritized and it with
presumption in favor of sustainable
development kicks in
and that's a high court I can give you
the reference number for the
for that uh high court and judgment the
chairman for clarity this is a golf
range so is not a person's garden
secondly I've already said this is
previously developed land thirdly I've
said our policy accepts that but directs
it to other forms of development before
residential and then we'll only accept
residential when these other things have
lacked evidence to be delivered so I'm
that piece of caseload say has zero
relevance to this application because
this is a golf course and the council
has accepted it's previously developed
land it's not a garden and we're not
trying to argue it isn't previously
development thank you chairman
councilor Morgan
I think about it I've just made the
point that um
uh with regards to the officers indeed
Council Stevens has appointed certainly
from my point of view I'm not ignoring
the capitals planning policies I just
don't think with great respect to the
officers that they are actually applying
them properly or in the right way I
believe that that in fact with the
sustainability aspect we've already
stated there is there is a
sustainability argument
Mr Lee spoke about the question of
employment
um I mean I I I can't see how a golf
driving range which is at the moment
which probably only employs sort of one
person I think sort of picking things up
Etc as opposed to a Village Development
which could you know encourage all sorts
of further employment matters like
guards and these other things I
appreciate he says that there should be
there could be some other employment
site on there but what I mean you know
everyone without advertising so this
this is this is I think uh a far better
way of making utilizing the site for the
benefit of all thank you manage but the
policy
we're straight into well that one didn't
advertise so we've been there with the
barns at Tottenham which to be fair you
won't remember but you know we had barns
that
should have been advertised weren't and
now their houses sorry
thank you chairman just in relation to
the sustainability point I think it's
probably worth drawing members attention
to the rural facility survey um that was
published this year
um so the settlements are set out in a
hierarchy so you start with your larger
Villages
um the highest self-minster for instance
it scores 220 points you then have your
medium Villages starting with Bradwell
at 69 smaller Villages Tulsa major with
40.
down and then you have hamlets an open
Countryside where wood and mortar would
a Mortimer scores 26
um and it's noted to just have a shopper
on commuter bus service and is 15
minutes away from a railway and there's
only a handful of villages for un the
scored lower
um
in that Village I think that just
highlights the
um and just on the relation of how
officers are applying the
um
policies just to take policy three for
example community services and
Facilities the policy says that it needs
to be demonstrated to the council
satisfaction that the existing business
and services not and cannot might be
made viable and effective marketing has
not been undertaken to demonstrate that
there is no viable and appropriate
alternative community service based use
and I don't think that's subjective I
think that requires the evidence which
we haven't seen here and it's in
paragraph 4.29 of that policy it lists
different community community services
and Facilities
um which includes education facilities
cultural facilities Healthcare sporting
local green spaces so there are other
options that could be explored that
haven't been thank you right I've got
cancer Stevens and councilor white again
and then I'm going to look for a
proposal no so we're going to come round
and round
we're all here for the whole District
right Council councilor Stevens then
councilor white and then if please do
make the proposal
thank you chair
um I mean you've both just said that the
points that I would have said which is
there is no evidence I've said it
already and you've said it and I'll say
it again that we haven't got the
evidence when you say
um what might what else might it be used
for well that's not up to us to find out
we've got the experts sitting here in
this room advising us here and I just
think it's appalling if we then simply
ignore them and I would urge people to
listen to what our experts are saying to
us
to think about our policies and what
they say
if you don't like the policy rldp review
process is is this place to amend it we
shouldn't just ignore it and say well I
don't like this bit of it today so I
think I'll approve this planning
application I would just urge people to
really think carefully and not ignore
the expertise we have in the room thank
you thank you councilor one
um thank you all right I'm I'm just I'm
quite pleased that or surprised that the
officer has agreed that
um it calls the policy S1 because it is
previously developed land
um and while this has been going on I
I've just had a job to my memory that um
we're the Three Rivers put in to build
the housing there I'm pretty sure we
refuse that a committee and we lost it
at appeal and they didn't give any
reasons for why it was sustainable and
their nearest shop is probably a mile
away
um and their nearest pub is probably 800
kilometers when there's nothing else in
um cold not there used to be a post
office there used to be all sorts of
things but obviously as time goes on
they'll close down so for me it's it's
privileged land and we didn't ask
um Three Rivers for viability reports
and anything else and whether the
business was sustainable and we lost
that at appeal we we turn it down at
committee I'm sure we did
um so I'm a bit jet like so brain's not
working well I'm I'm pretty sure that we
did so it seems to be we've done a
five-year land Supply and it's even
harder to get planning now and more
onerous than it was when we did have a
five year housing land Supply
first I would say it's a professional
point of view it's not more well enough
to get five gallons of fights just that
we're probably getting a lot of
applications that would never have been
submitted to us if we had a five-year
land Supply also to my knowledge Three
Rivers is still a functioning business
so um yeah if any of I don't know the
applications in front the councilworks
referencing as I always say if people
would like to discuss applications as
part of a agenda a part of discussion
they let officers know in France were
able to comment them so I'd advise that
members give fairly limited way to that
session but what I would say is if I'm
correct Three Rivers is still
functioning business so obviously this
application expunges that development
and therefore requires the evidence to
say why this should stop rather than
being a development that does not stop
the business so they're not comparable
in that respect
um so well I would say it's just on the
basis just you know just be very
conscious of that real allocations
because if we're going to be saying that
this is a sustainable location we are
saying that every single pretty much
every single part of the district is
sustainable because of the apart from
stoma is dingy Munden old Heath Road
ashfordam hazley little blacks did
Gladwell Waterside and Cox Clark they're
the only places in the district are
found to be lower in that survey so if
we're going to have a line in the sand
that is that low
um what facilities we require you know
that will become a material
consideration in future you know and
just be it's going to make officers
position very difficult forthcoming
appeals and planning applications that
you know may actually be higher up this
list and provide in other facilities if
we're going to say that these aren't
um you know as I said I'd like to
highlight again members thank you thank
you
well thank you chairman uh and look we
know the officers are not going to agree
with a lot so I just want to make one
other point and I've listened very hard
to councilor Stevens
um
it's rather a shame and with the
greatest respect to councilor Stevens
It's rather a shame she doesn't follow
her own advice because when we were
debating a development in tollsbury
which was recommended by officers for
approval
uh and we had their expert advice she
voted against it
um and she did not follow uh the poll
that was compliant with policy and so
she just didn't agree on that case so
you can't have your cake and eat it but
chairman
um I will and I totally understand why
councilor Stevens would have made that
decision and I probably would have made
the same one but I think let's not
preach
um chairman I propose uh that we don't
go along with the officer's
recommendations that we Grant this
planning application and I'm sure
between us and councilor white being
very on the ball with her policies
um but I think because it's a Brownfield
site
uh it qualifies under under
um section 111 of the mppf's presumption
in favor of sustainable development
um as well thank you as always shall
come back
um what I would firstly say is obviously
there are multiple reasons for a refusal
suggested for this uh application
um and I would advise as always that any
reason for approval talks to all of them
um because otherwise what we are saying
right now is if members approved this
based on that reason for approval alone
that any Brownfield site can be
redeveloped for housing irrespective of
location what's on site whether they've
evidenced the loss of not of why it
should be there
um ecology and obviously the sexuality
six obviously with four legs would
require that before the internationally
but I would just highlight that those
three first three reasons refusal and
the additional one on ecology
um talk about a lot of matters and such
a limited stance on this is previously
developed land we should allow it to be
turned into housing which is what that
reason for approval is would be a
ridiculously dangerous reason for
approval because it would be
regurgitated again and again at us
across a application again and again and
if that's the council stance we will not
be able to defend any application
against any employment site any piece of
built form basically any Garden spacing
um within a settlement boundary Etc
because this is saying that any
previously developed site is acceptable
for housing and that is not I would
advise not a very safe direction to take
the council in thank you chairman okay
I'm happy to help I'm happy to help uh
chairman yeah so
um the ecology we've addressed and that
we don't agree that there is an ecology
uh issue employment again we don't agree
that it's a significant loss of
employment we don't agree that it's a
significant loss of a tourist asset
um and quite clearly the current
business is not viable
um
whether the whether the applicant has
proven beyond all doubt you know what
are we going to do I can tell you it's
not viable I it's not business I'd take
on this for certain and um
chairman you know I'm sure between us we
can come up with some more reasons yes
councilor white is itching to help me no
no I'm sorry no I won't I need a valid
proposal from one person person then
we'll look for a second then that's how
it works you've got mine so whether
that's enough is another matter but now
councilor white can come in with some
others
has to make the full proposal
Council white is going to if you if
you're going to be like that chairman
councilor white can write them down and
I can read them out so my understanding
is from the training that I've witnessed
members have is that at the end of the
debate members
should be able to put forward a reason
for refusal or reason for approval Etc
based on the debate and whoever is
proposing that puts that forward and
then that is acceptable that is my
understanding what the training is it's
what I've done whether you agree with
them well no it's another matter
hang on Excuse me
yes I've had it confirmed by the
committee clock that we can't have
collab collaboration
um we have been through this before we
need to demonstrate that the person
making the proposal has
fully understood what they want to
propose and why therefore no
collaboration I accept that you've been
chairman this should address the reasons
for refusal although there's still no
evidence and when we've got all that
we'll we'll have the actual debate
because this hasn't been a debate so far
it's been a general discussion and then
we can speak for Against The Proposal so
what have you got councilman
it is previously developed land
it is sustainable
no
it is adjacent to the existing
settlement boundary
it is our belief that there would be a
net gain in biodiversity
um yes and that as my colleague says we
can condition that
um
and the other reasons I've said I mean
chairman whether whether it whether the
officers agree they are the reasons that
we're putting forward and whether you
agree chairman with the greatest respect
for you in the chair that that that's
that's what we have I'm not bothered
about whether I agree I only care that
they're valid and with what we're
lacking is everything
was going to second that are you happy
to second that I am indeed okay thank
you
um I've got councilor Stevens who I
suspect was just to speak against yeah
thank you chair I would say I know I
know we're not here to discuss the
tollsbury applications but please let's
not go there I would just say that the
reason I chose to speak out on that
occasion was because something had
changed which was environment agency
advice and on this application nothing
has changed and we can't just suddenly
say oh well I know the ldp says that
it's an unsustainable development but
tonight we think it is sustainable
because you can't just sort of cherry
pick like that
unfortunately we can and not not across
the floor please members
I don't think it's it's
not I can't think of the word but it's
just it's nuts to have that's not the
right word is it but to have a policy
that says one thing and then suddenly on
a whim decide oh well we don't really
think it is tonight not across the floor
please
um the only thing I would agree with
that's just been said is yes it's
previously developed land but there's no
evidence that it can't be used for
anything else other than housing
it's not in a sustainable location
according to our ltp it's only adjacent
to the boundary not within it that we
don't have the evidence about
biodiversity and so I don't feel that
those are compelling reasons for
approving this application thank you
thank you well I think we've had lots of
speech in favor of the proposal or the
gist of The Proposal so I think we'd
better put that to the vote no I'm sorry
um I have to say I agree we have no
evidence we have policy requirements for
evidence we have no actual evidence for
this proposal and I cannot support it so
those in favor of accounts
thank you Mr Lee yes this has to be
subject to the s-106 and delegate
delegated conditions sorry I was taking
that as read and I shouldn't have so
those in favor of councilor Durham's
proposal to approve
one two three four those against
three okay
so that proposal is approved
um item six any other items of business
the chairman decides are Urgent there
are none uh closure of the meeting thank
you members and officers and anyone else
involved I closed the meeting at 8 35.
and I give up